I'm very very happy to be introducing
Barbara Herrnstein Smith
you guys all heard the introduction by
Dale Martin on Tuesday so I won't repeat
any of that instead I just want to
recall the intense excitement that I
felt in the early 90s when I was reading
contingencies of value and if I had
known that i'll be doing the
introduction today I would have been
jumping up and down then for many of us
it is the landmark book the major
turning point in our thinking but I
think Barbara as usual has moved ahead
of us and has gone on to other things
many other things I especially remember
to talks that she gave here one call
sewing up the mine on evolutionary
psychology and the other paper giving at
a symposium in honor of Naomi shore call
animal relatives difficult relations
that is now a chapter of a new book
scandalous knowledge so I think it's
fair to say that even though Barbara has
been a Duke all this time that she has
been a vital and continuous presence at
Yale as well it is a great pleasure to
welcome her and today she's speaking on
the new naturalism to evolutionary
riddles
thanks very much YG it's nice to be back
again and nice to see you all again in
the last lecture I introduced and
discussed some characteristics of what
I'm calling here the new naturalism that
is recent efforts primarily by
anthropologists and psychologists to
explain various features of religion on
the basis of current findings in the
Natural Sciences notably evolutionary
biology and cognitive science I'm going
to continue today to discuss these
efforts first by looking at a study by
anthropologists Scott patran titled in
gods we trust the evolutionary landscape
of religion and then by reflecting on
them in comparison with the work that is
also naturalistic and also draws on
evolutionary biology but that represents
a rather different tradition in the
study of religion and this is the book
creation of the sacred tracts of biology
in early religions by the German
classicist Volta burkert so I turn first
to at rijn the title of a Turing's book
in gods we trust plays of course on the
inscription on US coins but in two ways
first by plural izing God which marks
this as a non theological study
confessional polytheism being an
unlikely possibility these days and
second by suggesting that matters of
economics will figure in this study as
indeed they do at rijn opens by posing
what he calls an evolutionary riddle
mainly what maintains religion among
humans in view of its apparent costs
what makes this an evolutionary
he explains is that the costs involved
are effects of religious belief and
practice such as programmatic altruism
and apparently wasteful expenditures of
resources and so forth that would seem
to reduce genetic fitness the answer to
the riddle he goes on to suggest here in
line with new naturalist thought more
generally is that many beliefs and
practices associated with religion
reflect the operation of innate
cognitive mechanisms that were naturally
selected because they secured fitness
benefits for our Stone Age ancestors but
he adds here more distinctively many of
those beliefs and practices also meet
ongoing emotional and social needs for
individuals and their communities there
by continuing to yield important
benefits for humans and making religion
a powerful force in competition with
science and other secular ideologies
adren himself is a widely traveled
impressively informed anthropologist
familiar with the thought and literature
of several cultures many of them
non-western this cosmopolitanism is
reflected in numerous incidental
observations as well as more studied
reflections in his book and it cushions
through vivid examples some otherwise
angular technical formulations although
as we'll see his account of various
aspects of religion is confined along
certain characteristic new naturalist
lines it offers a significantly richer
and subtler view of the phenomena it
undertakes to explain and a more
sophisticated view of the general
intellectual terrain that it occupies a
notable feature of a trans assessments
of the payoffs of religion the term is
his from game theory as applied to
evolutionary biology is his
even-handedness in considering the more
proximate effects involved thus he
observes that religion is not a single
level
entity but the product of a variety of
cognitive systems only some of which are
adaptive and continues quote even those
systems with an evolutionary history
weather is adaptation or by-product have
often been culturally accepted to new
functions absent from natural
environments and these functions may
have little systematic relation to
genetic fitness then he has a colon
followed by a quite long list
encouraging xenophobia or opposing
injustice supporting ruling clique leaks
or their overthrow facilitating
communication or con games relieving or
inciting anxiety enhancing or
suppressing sexual pleasure promoting or
impeding artistic creativity fostering
or hindering insight into ourselves and
the world around us seeking or inventing
the truth and the light end quote so
this is quite a striking list both in
its substantive scope and in its clearly
painstaking effort at balance with each
item from the standard catalog of all
the achievements of religion matched
against an item from the standard
catalog of all its crimes this continued
balancing act is sometimes hard for a
turn to manage and leads him to ignore
or soft-pedal certain features of
religion that would get added bite from
some perspectives to the debit side of
his accounting sheets for example the
long-standing clerical sponsorship of
the confinement of women which he
doesn't mention here in line with old
naturalist's as well as new naturalist's
I've observed but his emphasis on the
fundamentally ambivalent operation of
religious beliefs and practices for
better or for worse as he puts it later
is valuable as such and there's much
else to welcome here due acknowledgment
of the
of religious phenomena a refusal of
across-the-board adaptation ISM and do
recognition of the significance for
understanding religions of the cultural
environments in which they develop
indeed a trans study exhibits numerous
virtues of these kinds which is what
makes its participation in some of the
more dubious moves of the new naturalism
all the more disappointing where they
occur the extent of that participation
is apparent early on thus while atra
notes that given the variety of the
effects of religion we should not seek
to explain everything about it as the
product of innate cognitive mechanisms
his main point is actually the converse
of that quote where we do see a high
degree of similarity among the beliefs
and practices of people living in
different cultures then we may
confidently posit the existence and
operation of just such mechanisms end
quote indeed he maintains such cross
cultural convergence is quote possible
only because of the universal structural
framework of the mind which he continues
involves innate and modularized
expectations about object movements
essential kinds the intentional nature
of agents and so forth end quote so
through a more intellectually nuanced
route at Ron's account of religion
arrives at or takes off from a view of
human cognition very much like the one
that I examined last time in Pascal
boyers book religion explained I'll be
saying more today about that general
view of cognition but for the moment I
want to stick with the passage from at
Rijn that I just quoted a moment ago
akron sleep here from the observation of
close similarities in the beliefs and
practices of different cultures to the
confident positing
of universal innate cognitive mechanisms
is worth some attention since it's a key
conceptual move in the accounts of human
behavior and culture offered by
evolutionary psychology and in the
explanations of religion derived from
them expanding the point-after incites
as evidence of the operation of such
mechanisms the resemblance of the
Egyptian Phoenix to the pre-columbian
feathered serpent and comparable
similarities between Irish elves and
Russian fairies and remarks quote if we
reject the unlikely possibility that
these climatic recurrences stem from
historical contact and diffusion or are
spontaneous instantiations of a set of
innate religious forms and these sites
here young then how else could such
apparent recurrences independently take
place across cultures without specific
and strong cognitive constraints ?
rhetorical question but these are not as
he implies the only alternatives like
the virtually Universal metaphors light
and dark battles and journeys and so
forth examined by george lakoff and mark
johnson in their classic study metaphors
we live by the recurrent symbolic
content of folk beliefs may be explained
without invoking diffusion archetypes or
specific and strong cognitive universals
as the product of recurrent human
activities and experiences under
widespread human conditions the Sun
rises and sets cross culturally people
everywhere go on journeys snakes and
birds are found together in many regions
of the globe and so forth the recurrent
construction of chimeras of various
kinds that is imaginary creatures
combining parts and attributes of known
ones no doubt involves the operation at
general level of species wide cognitive
capacities and tendencies but the
appearance of such creatures in the
iconography and lore of spatially and
historically remote and otherwise
different cultures does not in itself
require the positing of innate highly
specialized cognitive mechanisms and
neither does the cross-cultural
appearance of more specifically
religious motifs later in the book
associating are allegedly intuitive
comprehension of the concept of gods
with children's allegedly intuitive
knowledge of grammar a turn writes quote
without such biologically poised
competencies the products of millions of
years of biological and cognitive
evolution a child's acquisition of such
a wide range of cultural knowledge in a
few short years would be miraculous this
is also true for any adults ability to
network such a vast repository of
detailed information in a mere lifetime
or for an anthropologists ability to
understand something of an alien culture
in a season or two of fieldwork end
quote the argument here familiar from
Noam Chomsky's theory of language
acquisition is that to avoid believing
in miracles of human learning we must
believe in a storehouse of inner
competencies for example as proposed by
Chomsky in the 1960s and innate language
acquisition device but in the view of
many contemporary language theorists and
neuro scientists I my foot no tears to
fill Lieberman and Terence Tegan Deacon
the existence of such a device with the
specifications required by chomsky's
theory would be hardly less miraculous
at ron's examples here of remarkable
human achievements learning to speak
one's native language as a child
mastering as an adult the basic
informational repository of one's
culture
and as an anthropologist gaining insight
into other cultures these are quite
different and individually quite complex
accomplishment each the endpoint of an
array of processes that occur over time
an adequate explanation of any one of
them would seem to require at the least
consideration of the types of
experiences and developmental processes
that might be involved and relevant
observation and analysis explanations of
observed achievements in terms of
positive energy so ever like language
acquisition device obviate the need for
such theoretical and empirical
activities or to put it the other way
around and it has operated this way in
linguistics such explanations for
clothes such activities before they have
begun if you think the only alternative
to a language acquisition device is a
blank slate alright then you are quite
confined in what you are likely to think
about or look at or look for in the
study of children's acquisition of
language I would also note that while at
rijn and other evolutionary
psychologists typically stress the
millions of years of biological
evolution they typically neglect the
many years involved in the maturation of
every human being what a traverse to
hear as a mere lifetime ought to move on
though to other dubious but instructive
features of his general approach
a key element of the new naturalist
explanations of why the gods persist
which is the title of a book in the
genre is the idea that supernatural
concepts are especially compelling
because they involve a combination of
intuitive and counterintuitive
properties for example it said in being
able to watch and hear us gods conform
to our innate categorical intuitions
regarding what personal agents can do so
beliefs about them are easy to accept
but the argument continues in being
invisible and immortal gods violate such
intuitions so ideas about them are
striking and memorable so it seems one
way or the other stories about gods are
virtually irresistible to the human mind
the hypothesis is also signaling the
unfalsifiable since whatever you have
it's going to explain whatever you want
it to although the theory is plausible
in relation to a range of examples its
assumptions quite aside from what I just
mentioned present a number of
significant conceptual and empirical
difficulties that I want to examine here
and because they are broadly important
for the new naturalist project one set
of difficulties involves the fundamental
nature of what we call beliefs as set
forth in a trans account the theory of
supernatural concepts reveal some strong
but dubious rationalist presumptions
that are evident elsewhere in his book
and among new naturalist's generally by
rationalism here I mean a set of classic
philosophic views about what is posited
as a distinctively human faculty reason
that operates independent of emotion or
bodily sensation and is also tropic that
is inherently truth oriented such views
are dubious because among other things
they assume
partitioning of human faculties reasons
sensation judgement will and so forth
many of them very ancient indeed that is
hard to map on to current
neurophysiological understandings of
cognitive process at ron's rationalist
presumptions appear in his arguments for
the claim that people everywhere
recognized quote a principled
distinction between intuitive and
counterintuitive beliefs I won't have a
chance to pursue this but he thinks this
argues for a universal rationality that
defeats relativism but that's another
another subject not to be gone into here
but in support of this idea of a
principal distinction between intuitive
encounter intuitive beliefs he observes
first that if common sense and symbolic
beliefs were processed in the same way
than the former the common sense would
invariably contradict the latter the
symbolic and second that if symbolic
beliefs were processed just like beliefs
of brute fact then I'm quoting him any
conclusion would logically follow from
any beliefs because people would ascend
to blatantly contradictory facts and
quote now it may be the case that many
of the cognitive phenomena we assemble
under the term beliefs from discrete
verbal propositions to ongoing
inarticulate behavioral perceptual
dispositions can be distinguished in
terms of how they are processed
neurophysiological II but a trans claim
of a shop and principal distinct
universal principle distinction between
common-sense beliefs about brute facts
and symbolic beliefs about supernatural
concepts is I think dubious on its face
and his observations here figure as
arguments for that claim only if one is
persuaded first that people can't Harbor
contradictory beliefs and don't assent
to blatantly contradictory facts I would
have to say sociological experiments
presenting with
publicans and Democrats with big
blatantly contradictory facts uttered by
their favorite candidates always notice
the contradictions and the other guys
candidate and never notice the
contradictions and their own candidates
it's a sort of finding that of
psychologists are always eager to relate
publicly and that's a quite recent study
so I say his observations about these
principal distinctions operate if you
believe that people can't Harbor
contradictory beliefs and don't descend
to blatantly contradictory facts and
second that illogical objection
translates into a psychological or
neurophysiological impossibility my
point here in other words to the point
where you have to posit a whole
machinery to make sure that there are no
illogical contradictions of that kind my
point here is not just that at ron's
arguments here betray a surprisingly
old-fashioned rationalist logis ism but
that here is elsewhere the conceptions
of belief fundamental to the new
naturalist accounts of religion are in
many ways ill suited for the task at
hand certainly for the cognitive
psychologists studying religion the
possibility of the ready coexistence of
beliefs that are logically contradictory
is an important one to keep open we
recall such familiar but paradoxical or
hypocritical seeming phenomena as
devoutly religious evolutionary
biologists seriously philandering
televangelists and atheists who thrilled
to the divine comedy in regard to just
such phenomena some notion of mental
modularity seems useful not however in
the sense of hardwired categories of
belief such as so-called brute facts as
distinct from so-called counterintuitive
elves or symbolic plumes
opens but in the sense of the ongoing
functional segregation and
context-sensitive activation and
inhibition of various ideas and impulses
I'll say a little bit more about that in
a bit other explanations for such
phenomena the seeming contradictions or
hypocrisy zar also available for example
apparently contradictory beliefs are
evidently subject to modes of mediation
inter translation or as it is said
reconciliation that permit
compatibilities that exceed the spaces
of classical logic but are nevertheless
subjectively viable we'll see examples
of these next time and efforts by some
contemporary theologians to reconcile
scientific knowledge and religious
conviction I would add that rationalist
conceptions of belief as logically or
illogically linked propositions become
especially problematic in relation to
the understanding of religion thus
Daniel Dennett in his recent book
breaking the spell that I'll be talking
about more in the fourth lecture dennett
noting the violations of common sense in
what he takes to be the relevant creedal
beliefs rehearses arguments they were
made in the past by Hume and Freud to
the effect that ostensibly religious
people at least educated ones in modern
times can't and don't really believe
their beliefs contrary to such arguments
and to at ron's apparent suppositions it
could be maintained that logically or
rationally speaking our beliefs are
always more or less incoherent
fragmentary and conflicting or as i call
them elsewhere scrappy meaning in bits
and pieces scraps and conflictual like
fight scrap the evidence was such a
claim is ample thus classicist paul vein
in his book wonderful book titled did
the Greeks believed
they're leavin their gods makes clear
that an historically adequate answer to
that question cannot be given in terms
of such standard distinctions as real
versus imagined true versus fictional or
even the classic logos versus mythos
similarly catherine Bell a scholar of
Asian religions observes that belief in
spirits among the Chinese exhibits
widely varying types of conviction
within as well as among individuals she
concludes quote there is little to
suggest that a belief in spirits is
anyone sort of belief there is in other
words very little systematic coherence
end quote or again Robert or C professor
of religion at Harvard reports his
bemusement at finding that some of his
students from what he calls bible
reading homes rather than simply
rejecting their parents beliefs quote
have put together intricate Christian
understandings that draw on neo-paganism
snippets of Asian religions popular
psychology and contemporary science
fiction end quote comparable cognitive
assemblages characterized by fragmentary
inconsistent ingredients with widely
varying provenances that is coming from
all over and significantly different
modes registers and degrees of
conviction that are context-sensitive
have been documented and theorized by
numerous other researchers and scholars
and of course we're all aware of the
diverse array of ideas and dispositions
that we each carry around in our own
heads and I would add bodies
emotion-laden memories and habits
creedal statements learned in childhood
individually worked out convictions that
vary in strength and articulate pneus
from one context to another and so forth
in the face of such empirical and
introspective evidence the stalwart
rationalism of many cognitive theorists
is itself I think a notable phenomenon
of human cognition other questions about
the new naturalist account of
supernatural concepts are raised by
ethnographic observations that
challenged both the sharp distinction
between intuitive and counterintuitive
properties and their joint association
with specifically supernatural entities
thus anthropologist Maurice blocked
notes that among many people who worship
ancestors attitudes toward the latter
are not very different from attitudes
and even behavior toward living elders
quote I enjoy this particularly the
motivations emotions and understanding
of elders and ancestors are assumed to
be the same ancestors are simply more
difficult to communicate with when rural
malagasy in perfectly ordinary contexts
want to be overheard by the dead they
speak more loudly something they often
also do when they want elders to take
notice since these are often deaf the
ancestors are not as close as living
parents or grandparents but they're not
all that distant end quote block also
observes more generally that attributes
of God's ghosts spirits or ancestors
that are acknowledged by people in
ritual or mythological context that is
when that's what's being done and said
are often doubted or rejected by them
under other conditions for example in
professional or for some of the people
he has studied formally philosophical
contexts moreover he adds what was once
strange striking and thus
counterintuitive for someone for example
the idea of a personal deity who is
invisible sees everything at once rises
from the
and lives forever in a world of spirits
may become for the born-again or
otherwise converted familiar routine and
thus for that person intuitive I want to
insert something else here that is just
a point about cognitive norms that I've
written about before in connection with
the animal paper that watching mention
but I think it has a pertinence here as
well clearly not all cognitive norms
those so-called default settings in
relation to which we are said to
experience concepts as either intuitive
or counterintuitive are innate universal
or hardwired if any of them are many
such norms for example those involving
correct gender behavior are socially
transmitted and reinforced by individual
experiences in particular social and
cultural environments thus either why
aren't those women properly veiled or
why do their women cover themselves up
like that these are felt as you know
very wrong outrageous objectionable
something very bad we've been reading
about it in the in the newspapers
moreover all cognitive norms including
those with arguably innate components
can be significantly adjusted or we
could say rewired sometimes this occurs
as a result of expanded experience in
different social environments sometimes
in responsive correspondence with other
powerful cognitive norms subsequently
learned or otherwise developed for
example in the case of head scarves
principles of individual autonomy or
expectations of social tolerance
contrary then to the idea that
intuitiveness and counterintuitive pneus
are the inherent properties of concepts
or the automatic outcome of universal
cognitive mechanisms it seems that the
experience of an idea as either obvious
or strange proper or outrageous is both
culturally continued
and individually shifting finally in
this connection we may note the
difficulties involved in the
identification of the combination of
intuitive and counterintuitive
properties with specifically
supernatural concepts certainly one
finds throughout human history as well
as across the globe presumptively mortal
beings who nevertheless appear to some
of us to have been endowed with
extraordinary and not quite human
characteristics Socrates and Shakespeare
Jesus and Gandhi Alexander and Napoleon
greta garbo and maria callas geniuses
prophets heroes and superstars fixed in
the cultural heavens their powers the
object of our enduring or and sometimes
literal worship as block puts it the
counterintuitive is everywhere but if
this seems to be the case the
supernatural is historically culturally
and individually contingent and the
counter intuitive is everywhere then
we're in particular we may ask is the
new naturalist's religion the answer I
would suggest is that it is nowhere in
particular because everything that is
said by the new naturalist to comprise
it is found everywhere in human culture
and experience as i think is clear i am
sympathetic to the general long-standing
ongoing project of producing
naturalistic accounts of religion but
skeptical about many aspects of the
particular approach i am calling here
the new naturalism especially the
understanding of human cognition central
to that approach that understanding is
not in my view completely wrong various
features of the computational modular
model are workable i think is formulated
and modified by cognitive theorists less
committed to the paradise
adopted from AI largely by evolutionary
psychologists in the 1990s nor am I
suggesting here that the new naturalist
accounts of religion are altogether
worthless or doomed to inadequacy but
they are limited i think by the
theoretical assumptions and
methodological allegiances that i
discussed just now and last time
conversely those accounts are most
substantial persuasive and illuminating
when joined to empirically responsive
studies of religion by scholars and
researchers working with other
approaches both social scientific and
humanistic these include textual
historical and archaeological
scholarship and efforts to describe and
understand religions from the
perspective of those who participate in
them to illustrate some of these points
I turn now to another recent account of
religion that drew us centrally on
evolutionary theory namely Walter Balter
burkitt's creation of the sacred tracts
of biology in early religions birketts
book though thoroughly naturalistic is
not an example of what I've been calling
the new naturalism rather in offering a
series of perspectives on religion
without pretensions to hard scientific
status itself it underscores the promise
of a biologically and otherwise
scientifically informed approach that is
also in his words tied to historical and
fill a logical research Birkett is not
himself a psychologist or anthropologist
but a classicist specializing in
civilizations of the ancient world Egypt
Mesopotamia Greece Rome and others as
documented in literary historical and
religious texts and revealed in
archaeological artifact
it's in these ways and others his book
participates in the long tradition of
naturalist accounts of religion that I
mentioned in the first lecture which
includes works by among others Hume
Nietzsche Faber and Durkheim Birkett is
also like here like Boyer at rijn
Dennett and other new naturalist's
extremely knowledgeable about current
research in paleoanthropology
primatology population genetics and game
theory as well as contemporary
evolutionary theory but creation of the
sacred originally the Gifford lectures
for 1989 was published in 1995 was
written before and without benefit of
either evolutionary psychology or
cognitive science per se and i would
suggest without many of their costs as
well in his book Birkett explores and
explores ancient ideas of invisible
powers and superior beings analyzes
recurrent patterns of cultural belief
and practice clustering around concepts
of guilt and sacrifice and discusses
prayer gifts oats divination moral
commands and many other familiar
features of religion all with continuous
reference to general human perceptual
and behavioral tendencies and he refers
these tendencies in turn to the
capacities and responses probable or
observed of early hominids primates and
animals more generally but he does not
seek to explain any of these either the
religious behaviors or the cognitive
capacities and responses as products of
hardwired mechanisms or mental modules
moreover while like most new
naturalist's Birkett is attentive to
recurrent types of belief and behavior
he's no less attentive here more
distinctively
to recurrent patterns of interrelated
concepts practices and social
institutions also in here quite unlike
most new naturalist's in describing and
explaining ancient ideas and practices
he's concerned to register the ranges of
their variation under different
historical and cultural conditions the
title of burkitt's book you recall is
creation of the sacred not discovery of
the sacred as el yada and other
theologically oriented scholars of
religion might have preferred but also
not mental foundations of the sacred as
Boyer adren and other new naturalist's
might prefer I have time here to draw
only a few examples from the book to
make these points but would recommend
all of it as an exemplary work in the
genre and a very engrossing read in a
central chapter tracking the biological
origins of ideas of dominance in
religion Burkert observes that the word
God or what we translate as such in
various ancient languages commonly means
power rule and honours do religion he
comments quote is generally accepted as
a system of rank implying dependence
subordination and submission to unseen
superiors end quote this includes the
Christian idea of omnipotence implicitly
related to ancient views of social rank
and honor themselves connected to more
primitive dominance relations among
humans built on physical strength and
height which can in turn be traced back
to fundamental patterns of ranking
pecking order among primates and other
animals such dominance relations among
humans birgit observes always includes
some form of mutual obligation in effect
a social exchange contract captured by
the formula found in
ancient persian texts quote the Lord
honored by submission grants protection
and ensure security end quote Birkett
notes in the wake of Freud moderns will
translate this pattern into
psychological terms explaining God as a
father figure or after feminism he adds
as a mother figure but he continues we
must go back further and account for the
role of authority in both society and
the structure of the psyche and it's
that combination I want to stress for a
moment a key point in burkitt's view is
that power operates through what he
calls a two tiered structure in
submitting to God one rises to power
among mortals as the father bends to God
so he may expect his children to bend to
him this religious theater of power he
knows still tends to manifest itself in
the normal family structure the common
family structure we could say it sought
to say what's normal he continues quote
submission and sovereignty occupy the
same hierarchical structure dependence
on unseen powers mirrors the real power
structure that is in the social world
but is taken to be its model and to
provide its legitimization in reality
while power games are played out and a
continuous dialectic of aggression and
anxiety in the stabilized structures of
the mental world this duality has become
neatly dissociated producing fear of god
or gods along with constant readiness to
attack and destroy lower humans buffered
by the good conscience provided by piety
and quote this subtle but unsentimental
analysis
one can quarrel with its details it's
the form of the analysis that I'm
interested in here recalls both
Nietzsche and Foucault Nietzsche
especially especially in the idea of a
dialectics of power at the heart of much
human social life Foucault in the idea
of the inter legitimation of
hierarchical relations in church state
and family an analysis of this kind
though drawing on evolutionary biology
is remote from the sort of mental
mechanism account familiar from
evolutionary psychology and the dynamics
it describes would be difficult to
render in terms of game theory or
rational choice models of human behavior
this is not saying that those models are
useless or wrong it's just saying that
this is a type of analysis that it would
be hard to render in those terms which
are generally accepted to be highly
idealizing and in other ways perhaps not
as descriptive as they are sometimes
thought to be I would note especially
that in explaining the emergence of
patterns of dominance and Submission in
religion Burkert does not leap directly
from primate behavior and presumed Stone
Age conditions to the positing of innate
universal human impulses or intuitions
rather he takes his way overland tracing
the many forms of social and political
institution and psychological processes
involved in the development of those
patterns over the course of documented
human history documented human history
always as opposed to inferred
prehistoric human development in a
central chapter of the book dealing with
guilt and causality burkhard identifies
another recurrent pattern of linked
human experiences and behaviors namely
the temporal sequence and he suggests
projected causal Nexus of catastrophe
guilt Redemption and salvation
his outline of the sequence goes as
follows I'm just going to include some
details here from some later
elaborations that he gives quote the
catastrophe or evil for example plague
pestilence storms earthquakes or defeat
in war the common the common supposition
that this is due to the wrath of a god
the mediation by the Oracle seer priest
or prophet the statement of religious
and moral guilt and thus assignment of
causal responsibility and the atonement
through religious ceremonies which are
essentially acts of undoing reversal or
restitution and quote the sequences
familiar of course from Homeric poetry
Greek drama and classic theories of
tragic form but Burkert notes it
transcends Greek civilization and may
practically be called Universal in
analyzing the pattern he posits a
commonality or continuity of human and
animal experience specifically the
experience of being fettered or bound by
bad things as a certifiable hospitalized
oval claustrophobic I might have we
found this particularly resonant but
this seems to be what he's talking about
the just the general experience of being
fettered or bound by bad things literal
physical confinement as in a trap or
prison or more general suffering
deprivation or disability not being able
to do what one what go what one wants to
go and of seeking to achieve release
again literal or more abstract it is he
writes basically a biological experience
and is such much older than humanity but
abstracted alaga rised and elaborated in
human imagination and culture
part of what grounds an analysis of this
kind empirically but also makes it
evocative and I think illuminating is
that it appeals to a familiar the
complex subjective experience as well as
to observed behaviors insofar as it does
so however this is a type of biological
explanation unavailable to the new
naturalism which is programmatically
anti phenomenological that is most new
naturalist's reject as useless or
improper for scientific explanation
descriptions of experience general as
well as specifically religious from the
perspective of the subject the rejection
reflects a set of controversies crucial
at the turn of the last century and
shaping experimental psychology as a
discipline and rehearsed many times
since and disputes over proper
methodology in the field of religious
studies in the case of psychology
seeking to distinguish itself from
philosophy and attain scientific status
the issue was the validity of the
introspective reports of experimental
subjects where the objective is to be
objective such data are of course
problematic in the case of religious
studies seeking to distinguish itself
from theology the issue has been how to
establish its intellectual credentials
as an academic discipline while
preserving religion from being as is
said explained away where the aims to be
friendly to religion a phrase I
encounter over and over this is friendly
to religion or is it not friendly to
religion where the aim is to be friendly
to religion a phenomenological approach
meaning here both bracketing the
question of truth that is suspending
both belief and disbelief and describing
religion from the perspective of its
practitioners has seemed eminently
desirable or indeed exclusive
Lisa for the new naturalist's themselves
seeking scientific status for their
evolutionary cognitive causal
explanations of religion the prevalence
of the latter conviction that is the
idea that religion is best or only
describable from the perspective of the
religious has been a key frustration so
it's not surprising that they should
reject such descriptions in their own
work not surprising but to a certain
extent self-limiting far as we saw last
time in Pascal boyars dubious efforts to
explain religious rituals the experience
experiences and interpretations of
participants which he sought
programmatically to exclude form a
crucial link in precisely the causal
chain of their emergence and persistence
this brings me to some general points
regarding burkitt's relation to the new
naturalist's in a final reflection on
the sequence from catastrophe through
guilt to expiation and salvation Burgert
observes quote people are quite inclined
to accept their own guilt a readiness
which makes the course of events
understandable and offers a way to
handle or refashion one's own fate in
contrast to the oppressive burdens of
chance and necessity and he adds in a
passage of particular interest to us
here will go back to such passages next
week modern science will not easily
prevail people prefer to cling to the
surplus of causality and cents and there
is no lack of mediators to explore the
hidden connections that is to assign the
guilt the passage just quoted is clearly
the product of a sophisticated
intelligence like many passages in
boyars religion explained it's concerned
with the power and profound sources of
human irrationality its angles and
idioms however are remote from those
boyer and most other new naturalist's
that is from a concern with scientific
per se and from a focus on the automatic
operation of mental mechanisms moreover
precisely because here is throughout the
book birketts journey from the
psychobiological to the religious
proceeds by way of an historically
informed understanding of human
institutions and behaviors it is
especially illuminating with regard to
later including contemporary
manifestations thus he allah rates
illustrates his last point here there is
no lack of mediators to explore the
hidden connections with contemporary
reactions to the AIDS epidemic and one
could readily add as further
illustrations the scapegoating rants
triggered indeed by the communal
catastrophes of 911 and Hurricane
Katrina comparable forms of explanatory
power and contemporary illustration
ulcery illumination can be found for
comparable reasons at various points in
the work of the new naturalist's as well
the contrast is not pure simple clear
and all the time and so I'll illustrate
that by going back to Scott a trans book
in gods we trust for some examples the
point is how it is that contemporary
explanatory power and contemporary
relevance are both secured by a kind of
explanation that does not leap from the
prehistoric to mental mechanisms but
takes its way as I say overland in spite
of the significant limits I discussed
earlier a trans accounts of religion are
item for item considerably richer and
subtler than those in most other recent
works invoking [ __ ]
evolutionary approaches these virtues
are especially evident in his analysis
of the communal effects of religious
beliefs and practices for example how
religiously sanctioned communal norms
operate ecologically in explicit
contrast here to the idea of an
inevitable tragedy of the Commons as
elaborated recently by Jared Diamond
with regard to the devastation of Easter
Island which diamond suggests was the
product of the environment two-stroke
destroying beliefs and ultimately
suicidal rituals of its inhabitants
Akron evokes an environment and
self-preserving spirit of the Commons
animism and anthropomorphism embodied in
religious norms he observes are
generally conducive to a cooperative
relation with the environment and thus
to effective ecological management for
example concerns about crops and animals
transmitted through local myth and lore
as preferences or punishments of the
spirits may operate as instructive
summaries of empirical observations of
interactions between humans and other
species over many generations at the
same time and in defiance of how costs
and benefits are figured in rational
choice models of human behavior members
of communities with such beliefs tend to
regard nonhumans from fish to forests
not simply as material resources but as
players in the same ongoing life game as
humans in other words he's not rejecting
the idea of game theory but he's saying
that what counts as a player in that
game will affect what the payoff is for
all concerned and that if there is
anthropomorphism and animism with regard
to the natural resources then you will
have a different way in which the
rational choice model will operate so
it's not just a matter of let's be nice
and forget about all these Economist's
it
is as is often the case and opposing
reductive econo mystic explanation is
counting the coins more carefully and
being sure that what you're counting
isn't always a matter of coins because
that usually isn't always what is going
to be involved adren does not sponsor
the sacral ization of major as a form of
environmentalist prudence as some dude
in a court however with other ecological
theorists he observes that where it has
existed the projection of an intentional
reciprocity between humans and spirits
has preserved natural resources over
time where evolutionary pressures toward
individual self interest alone might
have destroyed them although the
cognitive mechanisms at rijn invoke
invokes here anthropomorphism animism
projection and so forth are understood
to have evolutionary histories his
analysis departs from standard new
naturalist practice by considering
closely the consequences of the
interactive relation between humans and
their ongoing and current not just
prehistoric environments and also by
describing the dynamics of that relation
over historical not just evolutionary
time many generations not the usual
millions of years the analysis that
results is without mysticism but
certainly with insight and though its
generality may be questioned it has
considerable explanatory power and
potential value for practical policy
making these insight explanatory power
and practical pertinence seem to me to
be important aims and achievements for a
naturalistic account of religion none of
these aims however comes down to being
scientific as an end in itself and none
of these achievements exhausts its value
and being so
which brings me to a final example today
while the new naturalist's generally and
some of them spectacularly tend to be
tin-eared and literal-minded at ron's
explanations of key features of
religious belief and practice including
crucially their persistence gain power
from his attentiveness to the operations
of religious language he has two
accounts of it the one that I'm going to
give you which I like and an earlier one
which I have a lot of problems with
that's simply to be registered for those
of you who know his book well thus at
the end of the book arguing like Walter
Burkert that religion is unlikely to be
replaced soon by science or other
secular ideologies at rijn compares
science and religion with regard to the
fate of figurative language metaphors
analogies and so forth in their
respective accounts of the world
although he invokes here once again the
dubious idea which I talked about
earlier of a simple distinction between
symbolic and factual beliefs his
observations are I think otherwise sharp
and certainly suggestive he writes quote
where a science tends to kill the
metaphor that is as science progresses
its own metaphor disappears as a
metaphor that which had operated
metaphorically or analogically to
explain something tends to drop out as
it becomes more formulaic or as the
explanation becomes simpler and more
accepted where a science tends to kill
the metaphor religion strives to keep it
poetic and endlessly open to further a
vocation in the case of religion these
metal representational ideas are never
fully assimilated with factual and
common-sense beliefs they are displayed
discussed interpreted and reinterpreted
as doctrines dogmas sacred texts or
norms that further illustrate beliefs
and behaviors rather than
right of the world the fact that
religious beliefs do not lend themselves
to any kind of clear and final
comprehension allows their learning
teaching exegesis and circumstantial
application to go on forever end quote
in Daniel Dennett Sekou of the
persistence of religious ideas in
breaking the spell this unlimited
openness to reinterpretation of
religious language is cast as
mystification pure and simple a
naturally selected trait of certain
viral means that is popular culturally
transmitted ideas or behaviors
religiously incomprehensible ax t or
openness to endless interpretation of
religion religious language is seen as
designed to prevent the clear
understanding of religious ideas thus
protecting them from rational evaluation
and helping to ensure their
infectiousness and perpetuation although
then its account here and his
invocations of meme theory generally are
self-consciously Darwinian it's doubtful
as to how well they illuminate the
operations of religious language with
regard to the question at issue that is
the evolutionary riddle of the
persistence of religion it's a set of
questions to which I'll return next week
when we look at some theological
responses to Darwinian theory and to the
new naturalism particularly in the work
of John horn and also look at some
contemporary views of the relation and
future relations between science and
religion but I'll end here today thank
yes I will take questions I need to be
able to see you and I'd appreciate if
you would just identify your field so
I'll know where you're coming from and
the context of your comments or
questions yes is there an example of a
successful mental mechanism you've
derided the mechanisms for language and
religion wonder if there is a successful
model it's my first question second
question is what are the talents are the
tools the Berkut brings to his book okay
um I just try I should have a pencil I
appreciate anybody having just so I can
jot down the exact words of the
questions because thanks so much they're
all right I've given examples of mental
mechanisms that I think our unsub that
don't work such as the idea of a
language acquisition device as proposed
by Chomsky to account for the rapidity
with which children acquire their native
language and the question is whether
there are examples of successful mental
mechanisms in the first lecture I said I
believe that there are cognitive
tendencies that emerge reliable
in human beings the whole question of
the mental mechanism is a model of
cognition which I have a lot of trouble
with so again it's not that I object to
the idea of machinery I like machines
and I think that humans are machines and
I think that animals all machines I
think that we've got to get straight
though what kinds of machines organisms
are so that that would be the answer so
I can't give you an example of a mangled
mental mechanism that I think works
because it is that notion and the just
theory of cognition in which its
embedded that I am questioning more
broadly but that doesn't mean that I
reject the idea I invoke it very often
in fact get arguments from people i
invoke very often and will next time a
number of cognitive tendencies that i
think our species wyd how they get to be
that way is I think a question for
cognitive science and for behavioral
science to answer I am unhappy with the
current state of the computational
modular explanation of cognition as it
was developed in the early 90s by leda
cosmides john tooby and popularized in
works like Steven Pinker's how the mind
works that that's where my opposition
lies the second question was what is it
that Burkert has that makes him so good
I when I was trying to suggest is that
it's a combination of things I mean he's
obviously just tremendously learn it but
it's not the degree of learning and it's
not the fact that he comes from a
humanities Department rather than a
science department he's obviously made
himself very very thoroughly
knowledgeable about biology and
current work that would be relevant to
an evolutionary account or biological
account of religion he does all of that
is there but he has an addition is
simply both the habits the techniques
and the desire to deal with human
history over historical time so that
when we are tracing the tracks of
biology for to account for recurrent and
contemporary both ancient and as he
draws it up to the present rly recurrent
religious phenomena we have the richness
of recorded human history as part of
what we're drawing on in order to give
that account whereas in the new
naturalist accounts except when they
depart from that as a tron does he is
himself very well informed historically
that is not just in terms of prehistoric
inferences about prehistoric life and
notions of mental mechanisms but also
where that is stilled in my word is
going overland it means not making the
leap from what's inferred and positive
to what's inferred and positive but
moving through what is known of human
institutions social institutions
political institutions and being
attentive to the way in which these vary
in relation to the particular historical
circumstances all of that stuff it's
it's the thickness of that stuff that
makes what finally emerges as his
indication of a track from something
known to something biological seen
satisfying to me seems to me to have
both empirical adequacy and
responsibility and also evocative pneus
in the sense of yeah that's the way
things happen even if it didn't happen
exactly that way even if these details
have to be filled in even if his
particular what he's focusing on has
some particularity nevertheless
is consonant with my own sense of how
things happen how cultural institutions
and human behavior does tend to develop
thanks for the question Dennis Turner I
wasn't medieval theology which means
that I approach even deeper levels of
ignorance than the last castle extremely
naive question it's this you say that
you think human beings are machines
isn't this a very odd sort of claim in
view of the fact that it'll be probably
centuries before we can get machines to
replace human being I've been talking to
your colleagues who tell me any second
now we're I have oh yeah she need to do
every story's it's not sort of optimism
you get from scientists when they're
looking for large sums of research money
just so mine no question is this that it
looks to me just prime facie as if the
other way around is more promising that
machines are imitation humans rather
than humans are imitation machines or or
the human behavior could be explained or
the model on those are two very
different from two very different things
human behavior can be explained in terms
of what is called roughly mechanisms
certainly that does not make humans into
machines in some robotic way I will talk
about that a little bit next time
because the kind you just said the human
beings and machines I said there yes
Norman beings are machines and yes it
just seems very odd I mean in view of
the fact that machines are very much
less successful on what machines you're
thinking about one can think about
organism one can think about a cell as a
machine yes maybe okay fine I mean
that's insulting no no but I mean I
don't I don't want to make you you know
exhibit a
but it is the kind of clash of idioms
that your question raises which i think
is a tremendous significance in trying
to deal with the issues that the Terry
lectures were instituted to deal with I
think it's important to call these
things to recognize that that is what's
important a clash of idioms a clash of a
whole set of what it is that you would
associate with a machine what examples
would occur to you and also because I do
know where you're coming from a whole
set of issues philosophical theological
that are very very complex and when you
hear humans are machines I understand
that you hear it against the background
of those issues I would want to say that
I think you probably miss hear me a lot
of the way perhaps ultimately I don't go
to the places that you would want me to
go in order to deny that but I think
that for a good bit of them of the way I
don't have a mechanical no she I didn't
have any baggage of this I promise you
it's a really naive question just in
principle isn't encountering surety to
suppose that you can explain human
beings by reference to machine but that
isn't what's going on it is not that
human beings are being explained by
reference to machines it is that the
idea of human behavior and culture being
involved be explicable by something that
can be called a mechanism alright that's
not the same thing a mechanism and a
machine is not the same thing a
mechanism is the way something happens
yes I thought machines are about the way
something happens no but listen oh there
is logic even outside of theology and so
the fact that one is the same as the
other does not make it does not make it
in that case your you've reversed what
belongs in what category okay
brought me up short by your remarks
about language acquisition there was a
marvelous paper by a psychologist named
selling my old colleague from Penn yes I
used to play poker in the dying days of
behaviorism in which he pointed out
whether astutely that animals and
presumably people as another species of
animal are evolutionarily prepared or
counter prepared or unprepared to learn
certain sorts of things during
development yeah and I would have
thought that a that's well established
and that language acquisition is in fact
an example of a cognitive process for
which we are evolutionarily prepared I
don't disagree with that that is not the
same thing as endorsing the notion of a
language acquisition device there's a
little considerable space between what
you said which I have in print affirmed
I said to raise questions about that a
device of that kind is not to deny that
there are dispositions that our species
wide and humans they may not be
restricted to language I think they are
not i think we are we are very alert to
social cues very alert to the effects of
what we do on other people there are
numerous ways in which the learning of a
language could be facilitated by
numerous ways that we have evolved I
have no quarrel with the notion that
language is evolved or that it depends
on evolved tendencies and capacities the
specific notion of a language
acquisition device with the specific
occasions that Chomsky requires of it as
he offered it in the I guess late 60s
has been severely questioned by from the
point of view of human anatomy to the
point of view of paleoanthropology how
one thing could follow another well it's
like if I can couple this perhaps no
gone it coupled with the general more
general concept of module let me toss
you a hand grenade then and suggest that
what you are really complaining about is
the contemporary metaphor and not the
reality of what we can observe about
behavior we want to say that again but
that in my in the idea of module yes I
think I think you are not incorrectly
criticizing what is in fact in the realm
of metaphor given our state of
understanding of the brain and not the
process itself I'm trying to keep some
tangled in yeah well that's fine I it is
but we're talking about a scientific or
an account that is offering to be
scientific it is a model so it is a
model that has modules it has very
particular ways of being characterized
as domain-specific as genetically
specified as universal I mean so there
are a number of things that come along
with be segregated as far as process is
concerned so that what happens in one
model module cannot affect what happens
in another module that they operate
independently this is a lot of
specification that is built in or at
least that is asserted with regard to
modules as defined in evolutionary
psychology other notions of module have
been suggested which consists simply of
saying well a lot of things happen
together often so we can call it a
module so there's a kind
packaging what I call functional all
right functional differentiation
context-sensitive which is different
from domain-specific absolute
segregation there's folders model
there's the particular way in which it
was appropriated by cosmides and to be
there are other people like Paul
Griffiths the other Paul Griffiths who
the philosopher of biology not the
theologian who has also tried very
carefully Peter Godfrey Smith also a
philosopher of biology of science who's
tried very very carefully to distinguish
many uses and not mutually consistent of
the term module both in different
discourses but also within evolutionary
psychology itself so the problems range
from whether or not it's a term that is
used rather a certain amount of fastness
and looseness with in evolutionary
psychology in order to explain things so
we use it it's domain-specific here but
it's a more flexible over here it's
segregated there but it's combined a
ball over here so there's that kind of
conceptual problem and also the problem
for a number of people here I reach the
limits of my technical knowledge but
neurophysiological II doesn't seem to
work with what is being investigated now
in brain science yes
yes I can I appreciate that I'm in
philosophy and also give religion
specifically I agree with your
objections against naturalism the ones
that you stayed it completely but I
wonder whether there is not even a more
fundamental problem here namely this
when I hear these statements well of
course the worst one was by delyth but
all the others in a lesser degree calm
down to the same thing when I give these
statements that religion is this little
is death and specifically the emphasis
is exclusively for almost on the
cognitive function of the thing I do not
recognize religion anymore this is not
what I recognize as religion yes I had
the whole question is here that number
one the assumption the underlying
assumption appears to be that any mental
operation that cannot be reduced to a
cognitive function that the naturalistic
of explain doesn't exist well with this
exemption you cannot get very far I
would think that for one thing religion
discussed that way begins to look like a
science which is the last thing in the
world it is and it was religion is in
fact very often closure to what Susan
Langer in her beautiful books on the
nature of mind has defined as feeling
and by feeling she doesn't mean
sentimentality but she means the most
fundamental activity of the mind the
dawn in which support so-called
different so-called appetitive functions
go entirely together if we on the other
hand so the statements the descriptions
of religion I find in that is naturally
I find really amusing because they are
so far off base so far of anything that
even an ordinary person we can recognize
that a wonder how they get these things
take for example if you think I mean if
you are willing to go beyond the 19th
century scientists look at for example
what religion was but it was in the
Islam into the ISM and Christianity in
an earlier age but also but it is in
primitive societies but it is in also
contemporary human emotions as far as
I'm concerned religion to me is
certainly not a cognitive function
because I know darn well that there is
not a single point of my religion that I
can prove there is an element here of
course then immediately you tell you it
your turn to follow in falling back upon
a notion of faith which basically in a
scientific language either a science or
a substitute for science a bad science
that's not what it is at all it's an
attitude an action of confidence that do
agree I do agree with this very much and
that's where I think it through this
thing not in that all religious acts
have a cognitive element in them and
that without that cognitive element
there is no possibility of having
this act and a certain point that is
also implied i think we divide a strange
word super nacho is this that the
cognitive act is one that implicitly
always carries a notion of transcendence
in other words here is something that I
can't explain it may not be much but i
am not able to justify that it is
something that is more than what i have
in ordinary life and finally as a final
remark because i'm speaking too long but
the final remark i would say we're in
all this we're in all this approach of
the people that you have been recruiting
it that i'm happy to hear refuse it well
in all this is place for what is the
quintessential element of religion
mainly the mystical experience okay well
enough thank you for that set of
comments very very much the third i will
refer just refer to my first lecture i
don't think it were you here so I I did
mention that as in le AATA's analysis
and I said why it is that the
naturalistic explanation is rejected it
from various perspectives and with
regard to various phenomena and very
often it says it is said that it misses
the main thing in le oddest term it was
the sacred otherwise it's been called
the numinous or the transcendent so
those who believe that a naturalistic
explanation is intrinsically inadequate
as people do in various fields that that
is I know what would be said so I'd
simply acknowledge that that certainly
is a perspective your second point I'm
moving in the opposite direction is up
you are using the word cognitive and you
said that there's an essential cognitive
element and
it is a recognition of transcendence or
the unknowable I think cognitive you'd
probably agree with this is being used
in a different sense here from the way
in which the cognitive explanation is
being given that is you're using it I
suppose the way I'd use the word
epistemic just with regard to a certain
kind of knowledge and it's a knowledge
of is that correct so it just to
establish that that meaning of cognitive
is different from the way in which it's
used in cognitive science which is not
just concerned with knowledge it's taken
it's gone pretty the woods hard for me
to know anymore what cognitive means
given that it expands and contracts but
the first thing that you said I want to
agree with very much and it is my
objection to Dennett and I won't have a
chance to talk about it as much as I
would want to but yes I don't recognize
religion either from the description of
it and that's what I was connecting to
rapidly to what I'm calling the
rationalism and to the very notion of
belief and how belief operates in
religion the rationalism is partly a
notion of examining beliefs as if they
were propositions there are many other
ways to understand what a belief is I
mean even quite apart from any religious
notion of faith secondly by his analysis
of religion or his arguments about
religion which focus only on creedal
propositions is is indeed missing what
figures operates clearly for most people
who lead religious lives and for whom
religion figures centrally as what
matters the cradle propositions and
talking about their logic ality or what
their relationship is to one another
logically is just missing what is
mattering if he has refuted them all
very very carefully he will not have
achieved very much if that's what he but
Dennett who is
a strange this way he also says in
breaking the spell which you know it's
just stopped me he has this notion that
if only reason he believes that reason
is universal and that if the ayatollahs
got together with Pope's and the rabbi's
and all SAT around the right size table
and argue about these things rationally
that they'd come out to a rational
conclusion and everybody would agree and
go home because then we we know what was
the case for any one given his history
and give him what he spends his time
doing to still have such a naive notion
about how anything in the world operates
was uh just told me that he spends maybe
too much maybe too much time with
philosophers I'm going to suggest that
we continue this conversation over our
lovely reception there's some good food
and drinks out there and let's thank
Barbara for this interesting
you